[Music]
hot-diggity good Angela honeymooning a
trauma late what I'm attorney with care
to both of the sisters the offense what
we guys doing well I'm here with mu side
man and myself Ali Dawa you say with
himself not myself yes before I start I
want to please Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
the most nurse of the most trust or
praising glory and gratitude belong to
him we are here at Iman channel
brand-new Adel analyze knowing new show
and reacting the Quran what do we do
Musa what's what's react :
so reacting to the Quran is basically
react to the Quran water the show name
we open up the Quran to a random page
yes we pick a random ayah and we react
to it we ponder upon it yes and
inshallah guys feel free to join in with
us insha'Allah
let's get your bronze getting the
translation as well in sha allah and
let's get straight into it exactly some
verses might relate directly with you
guys you know you might see those final
actions what was going for today what
did it may be so yes Musa I want to give
you the honors today I've always
listening now let's do this let's do
this pick let's go right oh okay alright
so sauna and oh okay that is quite
interesting
surah imagine we are no we are between
surah at port and saloon hand and regem
so ok which one which one you're gonna
do a me I think you should pick ok and
choose one of the Arabic don't look at
don't read or non of in JAMA I'm
objectively there okay I'm gonna go with
this this was right here surah number
sorry i anumber 41 so that's over here
okay or have they knowledge of the
unseen so that they write it down or do
they intend their plot against you o
muhammad so but those who disbelieve are
themselves the victims of the plot
command or have they a god other than
allah transcendent easy beyond what they
associate if there were to see a
fragment of the heaven falling they
would say they would say a heap of
clouds then leave them alone until the
encounter the day in which they would be
Thunder stricken a day in which their
plot will avail them nothing and none
will help them shall carry on keep going
and very nice concise robust and very
easy and ready for the unjust there is a
Talmud before that but most of them do
not know so wait patiently o Muhammad
for your Lords decree for verily you are
in our sight and extol the praise of
your Lord when you awake and in the
nighttime also exalt his praise and at
the setting of the star extol extra
install I think they meant exhausted
they might be a time for here ok so
aside from which was 40 41 okay so here
allah subhanaw taala
yeah this basically you see one of the
things that you'll notice that a lot of
hardware that does is he mentioned like
key questions yeah so unique and and one
is questioning do we make Ya Allah does
Allah so for example Allah is asking o
has the knowledge of the unseen so they
write down so I'm not asking he knows
it's a rhetorical you see what we have
to understand it's a rhetorical question
yes so for example let's say I know
about something and I'm not like you
know do you know really okay do you
understand so a lot of on earth Allah
but it oh they have have they good other
than Allah so Allah is asking a
rhetorical question here to make us
think yeah so so kind of not if they
were to see a fragment of the heaven
falling they would say a heap of clouds
so Zohan Allah even if they were to see
something as miraculous as a heaven
falling they would just make an excuse
for it you get o allah subhanaw taala is
basically questions and then he makes a
point from that yeah so I think we
should see what the fear and kaffir has
to say about sin so we can get some but
when we go to that and very for the
unjust there is torment before that when
you hear the word on just what comes to
your mind
I'm just yet injustice you know someone
being oppressed
you know mmm okay you see a lot of times
over here like unjust
we think like like I said like you know
someone that's been endorsed or pressure
and etc but one of the biggest
oppressions that a human being does or
injustice that they do is actually
committing ship yeah this is the biggest
injustice but you're doing you know
because if you think about it you know
you're being when you're unjust to suck
to somebody somebody did you a favor
Moosa did me a favor if I'm unjust to
him then obviously I feel bad you know
some people don't you know but however I
feel bad you know that you know he was
unjust to him I sure Amanda etc now
imagine imagine imagine fear imagine the
injustice that's done the highest form
of injustice the highest form of sin you
know that is being done is that people
are living their day-to-day lives and
going about their business with no
acknowledgment with no praise with no
understanding of the blessings that they
have around them it's like totally
blindfolded you know you know it is like
imagine waking up to us like we said
before other episodes signs are not just
reading the Quran signs are all around
us so for me to wake up and just brush
my teeth look in the mirror brush my
hair not much for me to get ready walk
outside do my business whatever it may
be come back home go to sleep
see my family and the biggest injustice
that you can do is not acknowledge a lot
in the least not in the least you are
you you are just learning about in life
and somebody summit came to let's say
somebody came against our to a person
does not college I said look don't you
reflect upon you know your eye and the
way your crazes I know why was it to
reflect you know this is really
important because imagine you're going
about your whole forget this is one day
yes we're talking one day imagine your
entire life some portions of your life
you haven't acknowledged Allah in the
least what great oppression is that in
this imagine this one line there are
trees the animals everything praises
Allah they see the might and the power
of allah subhanho wa taala
Allah
some people that's living their life no
acknowledgement you know unless lean on
their it belief a belief in the Quran
what is the belief say to Allah
subhanAllah swear by your mic he says he
says yeah rugby yeah
yes he calls aloud by rugby rugby is not
o Allah rugby is like it's you know when
you're saying rugby it's like an
emotional thing as well you're playing
my lord
yes my lord it believes shapen yes is
saying to Allah my lord
and then we have some people even a
police is calling Allah his Lord
yes we have some people yes you don't
even do that subhanAllah us and they are
you worse than a brief yes yes they
don't wanna imagine imagine you because
what did you say take your own desires
is good because if you think about every
day consistently simply say I don't
believe in God well I know you do you do
but what do you define as good what are
you worshipping because every single one
of us are worshipping something it's
very clear we are worshipping something
some people are worshipping their money
some people are worshipping their
lifestyle some people are worshipping a
woman or a man or whatever it may be
what we're seeing is true freedom is
sounding what when you worship the one
that created you yes just a summer that
quickly is it it's just that
brothers and sisters when we get up we
should acknowledge but Allah has given
us a hundred odd squad of course future
of court house to live in and I've got
everything yeah I'm trying to see and
it's quite profound I want to read it
again and very least further unjust
there is a torment before that but most
of them do not know it just shows you
Allah because sometimes they are just
kind of for me to hell because I was
just unjust because you don't grass one
just is biggest one just as you need an
acknowledge nothing about Allah what
would you want in imagine if you guys
sent an exam and you didn't revise you
didn't even acknowledge the teacher
nothing and then when you fail the exam
I going to be upset I didn't know you're
going to know I did this I bought this
to myself so this is my reaction to this
and it's quite profound brother sister's
plan let's go straight to the syrup and
kefir inshaallah from ayah 41 to see
ribbon kefir for anyone that doesn't
know is basically an explanation of the
Quran so from I am 41 repeating the
meaning or that the unseen is with them
and they write it down means they do not
have knowledge of the unseen for none in
the heavens or the
knows and unseen except a lot okay 42 or
do they intend a plot but those who
disbelieve are themselves plotted
against and when allah subhanaw taala
when when the thing or do they intend
the plot is against the prophets of
Allah Allah Allah the exalted
asking do these people who utter such
statements about the messenger and his
religion seek to deceive the people and
plot against the messenger and his
companions if they do then let them know
that their plots will only harm them
therefore they are being plotted against
rather than being a swallow this is
quite profound this where Allah father
said if I'm I don't necessarily miss our
Karma but it says they plan and Allah
plans and Allah is the best of triangles
meaning look Robert what we need to
understand this we have laws in our
universe here if I pick a book up and
leave it it drops why it's a law Allah
said it's a physical law that we see and
there's a mythical in the school and
there's a metaphysical laws meaning when
Alice want Allah said indeed luma
remembers to heart find peace meaning
that means that our hearts are
programmed to only find peace in the
remembrance of Allah that's another law
here it's saying those who disbelieve
when you are plotting and planning
against Allah you're actually going
against the law
meaning Allah see look if you read again
a key it was from here or or do they
intend approach but those who disbelieve
are themselves put it against me to lie
against themselves we do it like it's a
law where if I get a ball and a city
against the world yeah it's going to
bounce like a knock me out
you transient going to come back to my
face that is a method that's actually
physical law which gives you summarizes
what I'm trying to say here meaning that
if you go against Allah and His
Messenger yeah you basically wait Eunice
you're plotting a planning to destroy
someone but in case instead you're
plotting and planning your own
destruction that's what's happening yes
one alive that is flat profile and a
half learner from now today I don't know
about you but that was very amazed and
very very very amazing so we can't need
to move one yeah let's go to verse
number 48 yeah
yes sure so wait patiently o Muhammad
for your loss decree for verily you are
in our sight and exhort the praises of
your Lord when you awake yes so Subhan
Allah this is this is something that's
very very amazing
was allah subhanaw taala is coming to
the defense of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu taala
by saying what we just explained yeah
where allah subhanaw taala
is basically refuting the idolators he's
speaking out against I deleted etc and
the people who do the biggest form of
unjust yes and then by the way what did
we say when allah subhanaw taala is
speaking about plotting then plotting
who are they plotting for prophet
sallallahu taala mia but here allah
subhanaw taala is actually comforting
yes
the prophet sallallahu saw will
patiently on I think so way put a little
pink really and we can all benefit from
that is welcome because some of us go
through struggles except whatever it may
be
so I'm lying wait patient and what did
he say for verily you are in our sight
the and exalt Allah meaning lo see
everything those who are going through
struggles and tests and whatever it may
be well whatever pressure might be
whatever country you're in that a lie
saying local this is this is directly
for you guys
so wait patient here let's go Muhammad
but we can say it look of course willing
on preferences right so wait patiently
for your Lords decree for verily you are
in our sights
Aliza forgotten about you so everything
allows for going about you Allah has not
forgotten about you and Allah knows your
test be patient indeed the decree of
Allah is promised so guys I don't think
there's much disabled yeah and if it is
very self-explanatory go yes very
self-explanatory that benefited it was
supposed to show you you know when
you're on the side of allah subhanaw
taala when you are worshiping allah and
you're putting him first
yes allah subhanaw taala will protect
you is he will protect your spell yeah
he will look after you yes just how the
prophet sallallaahu salam they may have
been plotting and plotting against him
but allah defended his prophet so no
Holly or sir
so it just goes to show you I know what
better friend to have then Allah and
very clear very true so Sarah Lee
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to for muscle Iman channel if you
benefit it keep tuned in we're gonna
have more of these coming in sha Allah
I'm loving this show genuinely don't
know about you guys I'm sure you guys
are so this Allah to next time Aslam
Allah climate or America
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo
hey give me one I'm Chucky subscribe
shoot shoot